[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Caitlyn
is in Milwaukee Wisconsin hi Caitlyn how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up um so I guess to get
short with it I need to figure out how
to essentially get my spouse he is
mentally on board with me but not
physically on board with me in not just
baby steps but Financial aspects in
general he has a bit of a addiction with
uh um instant
gratification
okay
um it's not an addiction it's not an
addiction it's just immaturity um that's
a very good point yes how old is he um
he is the same age as me he's 32 okay
how does that manifest what does it look
like his spending we'll put it in
addiction for quotes right now sure um
so he is pretty he's got a little bit
better I'll give him that credit but he
is pretty selfish um some examples are
instead of I mean the family car was a
decent family car one that that fits the
kids we out unfortunately outgrew it not
to him knowing um but then he instead of
just leaving it as a daily he needed to
um lower it which makes it more
expensive and ruins the car more then he
needed to buy a customized steering
wheel that abolutely wasn't needed then
he needed to do this he do that um he
soaked up your family minivan wow so not
the minivan it was a wagon it was his
daily that would still fit us at the
time not anymore but at the time would
fit all of us and then I had like a
daily um that was fit all of us and is
he creating debt while doing this oh I
can't even argue I I can't even like
fathom the amount like being a person
that before I met him I bought my own
house as a single mom it completely
destroys me like I I I have so much
stress from everything he's done
actually the last year I spent curing
like stress seizures wow okay um you
said you had children how
many um we had three children um one of
them is not biologically his but he
since day one has taken care for like he
is his she is his excuse me okay all
right well I I this is not a money
problem it's not a budget problem this
is a marriage it's a marriage problem
and so uh we end up backing into those
sometimes through budgeting and that
kind of stuff but there's budgets don't
control people people control budgets or
don't or in some cases don't do a budget
or in some cases don't live with a
budget but budgets aren't they don't
have any magic powers it's just simply a
road map maps don't control people you
just look at the road map and am I going
to go down am I going to go down the
road or not you know that's all a budget
is it's just a map and so um and and
wives don't control husbands and
husbands don't control wives as much as
they'd like to and as much as it would
be awesome if we could pull it off we
just can't do it um and so what we've
got here is as you said you know selfish
and immature guy who's putting his own
impulses ahead of the good of his family
have uh have you guys reached out to a
counselor that's what you need
yeah yes so we've done marriage
counseling already um that I set up that
then he denied marriage counseling when
he was ready no I know so we've done
these things because that's where it's
led to um I've
also he went two times to the one I set
up and then he denied going because he
was essentially being blamed for things
and he didn't like it he was getting
defensive and it's like well not saying
that I'm perfect but you know your
selfish habits are creating an issue
um then he set up marriage counseling he
also more recently is going back to
therapy for himself years ago but he is
going now um and now he is seeing a and
I don't remember the difference between
psychiatrist and psychologists but
technically I gu seen
both so he's got a lot of stuff going on
huh unfortunately yes um yeah the first
thing you said when you said hey we went
to counseling he didn't like my
counselor because this is that I will
say both spouses need to feel good with
the counselor because you know Sam and I
you know we we've gone to counselors and
it's been like I don't like her or I
didn't like him and you do sometimes
have to but if you don't like them
because they're telling you the truth
that's a problem yeah that is a problem
yes I he also didn't like that the guy
didn't get his name right a couple times
which I won't argue you know whatever
but um but yeah it it was mostly because
of he's telling him the truth and he
doesn't want to hear it yeah that's most
so he is going and he is going for
himself uh that's good I think the hard
part with this
is this is not necessarily going to be
mean that next week things are different
right like this is something that's
going to play out over time um and he's
still actively creating debt for your
family at this moment in time right or
no un unfortunately yes even though we
try to work out things that you know
give
him leniency isn't really the word
um if he's if he's running these things
up on credit cards is your name on the
credit card or is it just these are
cards that he's pulling out and he's
doing this on his own so he he had like
one in my name that he put in the
collections that then I paid off because
I was also on it trying to help him
build credit from when we first got
married okay and that one's closed um
yep and that one's closed um he did have
he's got three of his own he hasn't
touched credit cards in a couple years
and then he um then I you know he we
kind of discussed how we're going to
make things work and I asked if he was
ready and so he got a $300 limit back um
like two weeks ago and he racked that up
plus he had $100 cash um so he spent
$400 about five
days so I took the credit card away I
was like you clearly aren't ready you
told me you ready I think I think as a
rule of thumb and your family in general
you need to cut up all the credit cards
and no one uses them no one uses any
more credit cards so that's thing one is
we just don't operate on debt anymore I
mean my screen says that you know if
you're in in in the trying to do the
baby steps like you definitely cannot
use credit cards anymore so those get
cut up and then after that yeah you
probably do need to have a really a real
conversation about how his access is to
this money if he's just going to go off
and spend five and $600 I mean that is
that's a scary position to be in Dave
Caitlyn at some point through you
working with a counselor or working and
or working with his counselor the day is
going to come and it's coming pretty
soon based on the tone of your voice
that you're finally going to say
something like if we can't get on the
same page with money and you can't be a
grown man and take care of your family
instead of buying freaking steering
wheels then I'm not going to be able to
be here
anymore because you're terrifying
me I am awake at night I've never been
in debt like this you're out of control
childish behavior with money is
terrifying
me I can't live like
this so if you can't be a grown
man and learn to control your impulses
you're not a 12-year-old little boy
you're acting like one but if you can't
be a grown man and we can't get a a a
bead on we're going to manage our income
together for the good of this family
that will include you doing some fun
things and me doing some fun things but
it's going to include being a freaking
responsible grownup yeah and if we can't
get to that point I'm not going to be
able to be here and you need the
guidance of a good counselor on how to
say that and when to say that I'm not
suggesting you hang up the phone and say
Dave Ramsey said that sure but I'm
telling you if you do not get there
systematically and begin to put that in
front of him one day here's what's going
to happen and I know this because I've
counseled thousands of
couples you're going to have that little
switch that particularly ladies have
down inside them and it's going to blow
a
fuse and you're going to be done and no
amount of talking and no amount of
controlling and no amount of logic and
no amount of preachers and no amount of
nothing is going to get you back in the
marriage you're going to wave
bye-bye cuz you're going to blow a
gasket and you will have had it and I've
tried to reel these ladies back in after
they've blown it and show them that the
guy gave he gave in he gave in too late
she's gone all you see is her back
walking away she's done you wait you
just kept on you kept on you kept on you
kept on until she blows a freaking
gasket and you're it's in your voice I
can hear it so you need to keep away
from that gasket Blowing by getting some
coaching on how to bring him to bear
before you don't care if he comes to
Bear anymore this is the Ramsey Show